SALUT MAMAN
j'ai une nouvelle que je voudrais
t'annoncer en personne
quelqu'un a tué mon fils j'ai besoin de
savoir on a une piste mais je crois pas
que tu devrais penser à ça en ce moment
je suis triste qu'il soit parti je suis
enceinte
je veux bien t'aider mais tu dois parler
à des gens qui vivent la même chose que
toi c'est toi ma meilleure journaliste
écrit je sais que c'est pas moi qui ai
fait lui intoxico non je sais pas il
vendait encore non justement
il est parti en panique et ensuite bam
qu'est-ce que c'est c'est environ 50 000
dollars d'héroïne coupé
je voudrais enregistrer ce que tu aurais
à dire tu te souviens de l'ami de Mike
Doki on pense que Toky lui faisait des
affaires ensemble qu'il vendait de la
drogue ensemble un dangereux cocktail
héroïne coq et fantanile Mag a été tué
tout près d'une des maisons qui servait
d'entrepôt à Toky
de qui a tué Michael je sais qu'il
aurait jamais fait ça alors qui l'a tué
vous avez vu ce qui s'est passé
est-ce que tu te sens bien maman
tu l'as suivi l'aurait pu tuer
[Musique]
est-ce que tu as vu la personne qui
s'éteints
j'y comprends rien
[Musique]
pourquoi on a une piste
tu as vraiment envie d'aider et vraiment
envie de guérir il faut que tu vois ce
qu'il faut réellement ici
j'ai pas le droit de savoir qui a tué
mon fils
[Musique]
j'imagine que tu comprends ce que ça
impliquerait je le comprends mieux que
personne
qu'est-ce que je peux espérer
c'est la mère en toi qui le sait